the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we are going to talk about the
vibration of continuous systems not
covered on the quiz but it's a really
important part of real-world vibration
and the most easy it's one of the
easiest ones to demonstrate I've shown
you this one before is the taut string
but I want to show you something and
unusual about something you may not know
about strings
wait'll it calms down here a little bit
okay so this is your guitar string or a
piano string it's a it's under tension
we've already seen that it exhibits
natural frequencies and mode shapes so
there's the first mode looks like half a
sine wave has a particular frequency
associated with it they get it to stop
doing that so I get to do but if I
excited at twice the frequency of I can
do this there we go that turns out to be
exactly twice the frequency of the first
the mode shapes one full sine wave the
mode shapes for a taut string or sine n
PI x over L but strings can do something
else kind of neat
and that is if I hit this thing my way
till it calms down here if I give this
thing just pulse what do you expect to
see you're gonna see vibration tell me
what you see
what's that actually what do you see
happening something running back and
forth right
what you're seeing is wave propagation
it's not really vibration vibration we
see of its modes and standing waves and
things like that right so the taut
string behaves satisfies an equation of
motion that's called the wave equation
and we're going to talk about quite a
bit about that this morning and the wave
equation has has this name give
something away the wave equation
describes continuous systems of a
particular kind that support travelling
waves and so the string will both
support this I can give it a little plot
I'll try to just place it in a
particular shape and let go there it is
and that little pluck just goes back and
forth and back and forth at a particular
speed so is there a relationship between
the speed at which things can travel in
a string and the natural frequencies of
a string well we'll get into that today
and I'm going to start by just showing
you a little something that comes from
my research and let's see let me do this
I think this will work
you hear that now what's that what's the
as I go slower
this frequency go up or down that's kind
of slow and I'm gonna speed up alright
goes up as the speed goes up so that's
result of the phenomenon called flow
induced vibration and if you have I'll
give you a little very brief intro to
flow induced vibration you have a
cylinder sitting still flow coming by at
water or air what and it's let's see the
cylinder is diameter D velocity U for
the flow what happens behind in the wake
of that cylinder vortices are formed
it's just like if you're paddling a
canoe or something and paddle in the
water you'll see vortices shut off the
side and if you first should get one
that's positive and then one that's
negative and so one full cycle of this
is from here to here so that's there's a
frequency to this shedding and the
shedding frequency FS in Hertz can be
predicted by a simple dimensionless
parameter called the screw hole number s
tu over D and that's approximately 0.2 u
over D for stationary cylinders you can
predict the frequency at which these
vortices are shed now associated with
the shedding of vortices is a lift force
and I'll call it s M F L cosine Omega T
which is 2 pi F s times T so this at
this frequency of vortex shedding there
is a transverse force there's actually
an inline force also which I'll call FD
for drag and it goes like cosine 2 Omega
s times T it's twice the frequency of
that and so you get some inline
oscillatory excitation and what we call
cross flow oscillatory excitation and
this is the this is the
cause of lots of things that we the
people who work on it called flow
induced vibration now an amazing thing
happens is if this is cylinder is
elastically mounted or is flexible and
that force starts to act on it it will
begin to vibrate and the amazing thing
is it begins to vibrate it correlates
the shedding of these vortices all along
the cylinder so it's like soldiers
marching in step going across the bridge
and it yeah everybody's walking randomly
then the bridge doesn't respond too much
but if everybody marched us together you
can put a pretty good excitation into it
well the motion of the cylinder itself
organizes these vortex shedding all on
the cylinder so they're all marching in
step and that means the force is all
correlated on the length and you can get
some pretty substantial response so
that's the subject called flow induced
vibration and with that I'm gonna show
you a few slides it'd be good if we Elsa
dim the dim the lights a little bit if
you could to see this there's some
pictures I just want you to see better
all right so I do flow induced vibration
I've been doing this working on this for
all my professional career and it's
applied primarily to big flexible
cylinders in the ocean particularly
associated with the things to the US
Navy doesn't long cables and things and
also the offshore oil industry next
slide can we dim the lights can we dim
the lights
I want you to be able to see this is a
tension leg platform it's one of the
structures that's used in the offshore
industry to produce oil and you it might
one of these might be moored in 3,000
feet of water a thousand meters of water
might weigh 20 thousand tons and what's
connecting it what holds it in place are
steel cylinders 1/2 a meter in diameter
3,000 feet long going vertically down
from each of those 3 pontoon and legs
sticking out and they're under a lot of
tension and and in fact it pulls the
thing down into the water so there's XD
act the buoyancy of the whole thing puts
tension on these cylinders but now what
happens if an ocean current comes by
those cylinders vortex shedding and the
cylinders vibrate and if they vibrate
over time they will fatigue and fail ok
next slide there's a picture of a real
one that's a bigger one called Marco
Polo it on a launch ship it'll take it
out to the site that it is and then
it'll be ship lower and it'll slide off
so these are big next slide this is a a
diagram of the Gulf of Mexico South
America is at the bottom Yucatan
Peninsula is sticking up there right in
the middle at the bottom this is a
picture satellite imagery of currents in
the Gulf of Mexico there's a current
that flows up off of South America into
the Gulf of Mexico goes around in a loop
and then come out you can see Florida
sticking down in there on the right that
current comes out of the Gulf goes
around the tip of Florida and goes up
the Atlantic coast and is known as the
Gulf Stream but it starts as a big
current that comes into the Gulf of
Mexico and every now and then that
current pinches off an eddy and that's
what that red circle is in the middle
and that's an eddy that's many many
kilometers in diameter with surface
currents on the order of a meter per
second or more and those are the most
the biggest threat to 4:00 in Fort Worth
causing flow induced vibration failures
of long members from hanging off of
offshore structures next so I've been
redoing research in this area for a long
time this is a picture taken in the
summer of nineteen
one it is a piece of steel pipe about
two inches in diameter and 75 feet long
it's under 750 pounds of tension and
it's pinned at each end it is it behaves
almost exactly like my rubber cord here
has natural frequencies and it will
vibrate if a current comes by it so this
is actually a sandbar and low tide we do
all the work putting it up then as tide
comes in the flow is perpendicular to
the cylinder and vortices start shedding
and as the pipe begins to move they get
organized all along the length and a
typical response mode was when the
vortex shedding frequency therefore the
lift force frequency coincided with a
natural frequency then you'd expect it
to give quite a bit of response the
diagram on the left is if you cut the
cylinder and look down its axis this is
the trajectory that you would see the
cylinder make it would sit there and
just make big figure eights so up and
down vertical is its vertical motion the
flows coming from say left or right its
vertical motion is up and down inline
motions like this and they are and
exactly such a phase it just makes big
beautiful figure Eight's
that's the kind of motion you'd see okay
so then so very much what I was talking
about a minute ago very much behavior
dominated by vibration vibration in the
third mode cross flow was a typical one
and fifth mode in line was difficult but
that's a real as cylinders go in the
ocean that was kind of short third mode
vibration is sort of low so as years
have gone by and oil is being produced
in deeper and deeper and deeper water
the cylinders were putting out there you
get longer and longer and longer longer
and the modes that are excited by a
currents coming by I get quite high so
this is an experiment we did with
roughly a one-tenth scale model models
look almost two inches in diameter 500
feet long scale that up by a factor of
10 you're up around 20 inches in
diameter and 5000 feet long which is
exactly the size of the drilling riser
that BP had hung off the drilling ship
when the blowout occurred
it's a pieces steel pipe 21 inches in
diameter three quarters of an inch wall
thickness 5,000 feet long under a lot of
tension and it when ocean currents come
by it behaves just like this string okay
and so we're out this is a 1/10 scale
model so we put a big weight on the
bottom of the cylinder put it behind a
boat and towed it in the Gulf Stream
next picture so there's the boat it's an
oceanographic vessel is actually
catamaran next this is a spool that had
our test cylinder on it could lower that
there's a reddish object down in the
bottom which is where's the that's a 750
pounds piece of railroad wheel and it's
the weight on the bottom and so you'd
spool this thing off lower it down and
then do your test next top we measure
tension inclination and then it also had
a it's a pin joint at the top so it
would vibrate freely inside though were
was fiber optics next we had eight
optical fibers and in those optical
fibers were what we call optical strain
gauges so we had 280 optical strain
gauges instrumented up and down that
pipe so we could measure its vibration
and so you're looking at a cross-section
of the pipe there were two optical
fibers in each quadrant and each one of
those fibers had 35 sensors on it
next there's a typical experimental case
this is the surface this is 500 feet
down this is the current profile so the
flow velocity is about 2 feet per second
near the surface up to 4 feet per second
down on the bottom and this is the
region where most of the excitation was
coming from that would drive the flow
induced vibration this is measured RMS
strain caused by the bending vibration
of in the cylinders and peak up about
the max
strangers about right there next typical
response spectrum basically the
frequency content at three different
locations down deep in the middle near
the top this is frequency so this would
be the peak that describes the principle
cross flow vibration at the vortex
shedding frequency next this pipe this
is position bottom to top this is time
and these are strain records from all of
those strain sensors there's a strain
sensor about every two meters along here
but what you're seeing is this is
evidence these rent the red is the
amplitude in red let's say red is
positive strain and blue is negative
strain and so at any location on the
pipe where it's vibrating it's going to
go from red blue red to blue red to blue
and but it's showing you that they're
highly correlated all along the length
that there's a red streak all lined up
but it's not parallel to the pipe it's
inclined this is showing you wave
propagation the behavior of the pipe was
completely dominated by wave propagation
not by standing wave vibration so
totally different than that short pipe
in 1981 the wave equation
so it's imagine we have a long pipe or
string like that and it can carry waves
traveling along it and the position at
any location on here here's a coordinate
X we describe the motion at a point by a
coordinate W of X and T so it's a
function of where it is and time and the
way the what describes the motion of
something which obeys the wave equation
is the following equation partial
squared W with respect to x squared
equals 1 over c-squared
partial squared W with respect to T
squared that's what's known as the
one-dimensional wave equation and the
one-dimensional wave equation governs
incredibly broad category of physical
phenomena light behaves according to the
wave equation speed and sound
propagating across the room to you is
governed by the wave equation
longitudinal vibration of rods torsional
vibration of rods all governed by the
wave equation so it's worthwhile to know
a little bit about the wave equation and
what I showed you this morning it has
this kind of duality to it you can have
things that vibrate with standing waves
and mode shapes but the same system can
support waves that travel along it so
let's figure out why why that is so I'm
going to do the derivation for you of
the of the wave equation for a string
just so you where you know it comes from
because then that general derivation
applies to all these different things so
imagine you've got now a we're gonna
we're interested in eventually getting
to vibrations I'm going to make this a
finite length string and it has
this position will describe as a w of X
and T it has a tension T a mass per unit
length M so this is like kilograms per
meter is the mass per unit length of
this thing which kind of vibrate so
tension mass per unit length L the
length of it
what other parameters do we need that'll
do for the moment now so let's draw it
again without in some displaced position
and what's exciting it may be my vortex
shedding and so I'm going to draw on it
excitation here and that will describe
as a f of X and T some force per unit
length so this has the units of Newton's
per meter now in that little there may
also be drag forces the fluid damping so
I'm going to cut out a little piece of
this cylinder and do a force balance on
that piece of cylinder so basically F
equals MA we're just applying Newton to
this piece of cylinder and I'll draw it
right here it's a little section of it
it's curved
here's horizontal there's horizontal we
need to evaluate all the forces on it so
the tension on this end it's like that
and the tension on this end is some
different angle this will call theta 1
this will call theta 2 and I'll along
here are my excitation forces F
of xnt there may be some resistance drag
forces damping that'll be a damping
constant R of X which is force per unit
length per unit and velocity times the
force on this would be have to be
multiplied by the velocity so the
derivative of the discipline of this
displacement with respect to time that's
the force along here and it can vary
with position and if we accounted for
everything oh well we'd this is position
X and this is at X plus DX so this
little element is DX in length and this
is all for small motions
and if you assume small motions then you
can say theta 1 approximately equal to
sine theta 1 that's also approximately
equal to tan theta 1 and that's equal to
the derivative of W with respect to X
just the slope we're gonna take
advantage of that theta 2 same thing
it's approximately equal to the 2 tan
theta 2 here and sign and all those
things but that then the slope has
changed a little bit when you go from
through DX and this is equal to the
slope on the left hand side plus the
rate of change of the slope times DX so
slope on the Left this is now the slope
on the right hand side and so now all
that's left to do is to write a force
balance for that little piece
on the element DX so the positive upward
we have a t sine-theta
but because sine theta is approximately
tan theta is equal to DW DX then there's
an upward force on the right hand side
which is T mr. intended partial squared
W with respect to x squared DX so on the
right hand side positive upwards you
have T times the partial of W with
respect to X plus partial square W
respect to x squared DX that's the
upward force on the right hand side on
the left hand side we have a downward
force minus T partial of W with respect
to X and you notice that this one's
going to cancel that one we have minus R
of X partial W with respect to T that's
the velocity DX long because that's
force per unit length and that we missed
anything so that's the sum of the
external forces on this little slice and
that has to be equal to what a Newton
say the mass which is the mass per unit
length times DX is the total mass times
the acceleration partial squared W with
respect to T squared okay
so this cancels this term and then you
notice I'm left with everything is just
a function something DX something DX
something DX get rid of the D X's and I
can write Oh C did I leave it I left out
something I left out my distributed
force F of X and T DX it's positive as
it's drawn it's over here also so this
and I cancel out that DX so I put them
all together now and assemble them I can
write down the equation that governs
this motion so T partial squared W with
respect to x squared minus r of x times
velocity plus F X at T equals M partial
squared W with respect to T squared and
that just says that the sum of the
forces on the object equals its mass
times its acceleration now if we're
interested in natural frequencies and
mode shapes how do when we when we've
been doing one and two degree freedom
systems and we want to get the natural
frequencies and mode shapes we
temporarily let the damping be zero and
the force be zero right so we want to do
the same thing now we're interested in
how do you find the Omega ends and what
I call the sy ends because now the mode
shapes are functions and so this is the
natural frequency and the mode shape for
a mode end and we know there's lots of
modes so we let
are of X and f of X and T be zero and
when we do that I'm going to divide
through by when I do that this term goes
away this term goes away I'm just left
with T partial squared W 3 X - x squared
equals this and I'm going to divide
through by T so I get partial squared W
with respect to x squared equals 1 over
T over M partial squared W with respect
to T squared and this T over m quantity
turns out to be the speed of wave
propagation in the medium okay and that
is the wave equation right and as I've
just so we've just found the wave
equation for the string just by doing a
simple applying newton's law to a little
section of string you can do that for
the vibrate you're going to do same
thing cut out a little section of a beam
can't do the force balance on it set it
equal to the mass times acceleration and
for a beam you'll get a fourth order
differential equation and it's not the
wave equation still vibrates that it's
not governed by what do we call the wave
equation okay
so this is the one-dimensional wave
equation this quantity T / M is the
phase velocity it's called phase
velocity you know that's a good one to
remember for a simple string the speed
of phenomena running down the string is
the square root of the tension divided
by the mass per unit length and if you
had you know a long string and like I
put that little pluck in it you can see
that pluck running back and forth on it
that's the speed it's going on it's
basically it's called the well so if I
have my string and I put a little bump
on it and that bumps go zipping along
your I will see this thing propagating
at sea all right so to get natural
frequencies and mode shapes we basically
need to solve this equation and it's
quite straightforward to do and a
technique known as separation of
variables works which means that all
you're doing is saying I believe that I
got going to be able to write the
solution as some function of X only
times some function of time only product
of two terms and that in fact for
because we're interested in vibration
you can tell me what the function of
time is you're going to tell me how the
solution just from observation what is
it just the time dependent part it's the
same as anything else in my race so
single degree of freedom system what is
the time dependent function that we
substitute in to find the natural
frequency say again you'd be just fine
cosine Omega T work sine Omega T works
but e to the I Omega T is pretty easy to
use because it's so simple to take the
derivatives so we can guess that this is
going to be some w of x times a II to
the I Omega T alright and plug it in
hook it into our wave equation over here
so make sure I write it consistently so
we plug this into the first term it's
two derivatives with respect to X so
this is just and the time dependent part
just stays outside and on the right-hand
side when we plug it in here 1 over
c-squared
2 derivatives with respect to time it's
going to give me minus Omega squared so
minus Omega squared over C squared and
then it gives me back W of X a e to the
I Omega T and now I can get rid of the e
to the I Omega T's and I'm left with
just a an equation involving X only and
it's an ordinary differential equation
in W of X
so it turns into d2w DX squared plus
Omega squared over C squared W equals
zero and that that you've seen this
equation before does this not look like
have some similarity to MX double dot
plus KX equals zero okay the same
basically the same equation this one's a
function of X that one's a function of
time okay and we know the solution to
this one is some X of T is some
amplitude e to the I Omega T so
therefore we can guess that the solution
to this one as W of X is going to be now
write it as some B and now I need a
function of X but it can be just like
this e to the I and I'll say K X I know
that's going to be a solution so let's
plug it in if I if I plug that in I get
minus K squared be e to the I K X plus
Omega squared over C squared the e to
the I KX equals 0 well now I get rid of
these and what I found out is that K
squared Omega squared over C squared and
this has a name K
it's called the wave number and I know
it also happens to be 2 PI over lambda
we'll come back to that lambda is the
wavelength yes sinusoidal waves running
through the medium 2 PI over lambda is
the same as Omega over C and this is
called the wave number really important
quantity if you're trying to understand
wave propagation in systems and actually
and it this one this definition applies
to all wave bearing systems whether or
not they obey the wave equation it'll
apply to waves traveling down a beam as
well so the definition of wave number is
frequency divided by speed or 2 pi over
the wavelength well let's see we can't
go much further with this with just the
wave equation itself we have in order to
get the natural frequencies we have to
invoke other information that we know
and the problem in particular we know
that in order to get natural frequencies
we had to create conditions where this
could vibrate in particular I fixed that
end and I fixed this end and I put some
tension on it and now it'll vibrate but
it clearly has something to do with the
ends and its length and so this is a
boundary value problem yeah we have to
invoke the boundary conditions to
actually finish finding the natural
frequencies and mode shapes apply the
boundary conditions
so this I assumed here that my W of X
was going to look something like that in
order to do I'd get a little more
information out of than this I'm going
to right now W of X in a form an
alternate form that's equally valid and
I'll call it B one cosine KX plus a B
two sine KX and I could relate that to
you know e to the ikx be e to the ikx by
real and imaginary parts and so forth
this is a real part I'm saying in
general could have a cosine part and
also a sine part but now I know my
boundary conditions are w at x equals 0
w of 0 is what what's the displacement
at x equals 0 hmm zero
that's the pin that's the end where it's
fixed at and this is a we're started out
here with a second-order partial
differential equation and a second-order
equation requires two boundary
conditions a fourth order equation for
the beam will require four boundary
conditions we only have to find two one
of them is it has no motion on the left
so you plug in 0 for X cosine of 0 is 1
sine of 0 is 0
so we find out that this is B 1 times 1
but it has to be 0 as the boundary
condition so that implies B 1 is 0
there's no cosines in this answer and W
at L is 0 and so that says be 2 sine K L
equals 0 and that's true that's only
true if K L equals and PI so now I've
found out that there's just for
vibration of a finite length string
there's only particular values of K that
so that says that there are special
values of k which i'll kill k sub in
which are equal to n pi over l and from
that we now have our mode shapes because
we can say ah well there's special
solution for this w of X that applies
only when we satisfy the boundary
conditions and that will be some
undetermined amplitude b2 came from the
sine term and those are our mode shapes
and now the natural frequencies once you
know mode shapes natural frequencies
actually become pretty trivial to find
in this case if we know that's the mode
shape then how do we get the natural
frequencies well we know that what's the
definition of K therefore especially the
particular values of K it's that were
allowed solutions here are going to be
correspond to particular values of Omega
N and therefore Omega N squared is just
K and squared C squared and that's in pi
over l squared T over yep that's Omega N
squared so natural frequencies of a
string
our n PI over L root key over it and
then in this is in radians per second
and we like I like to work and hurt
sometime so the natural frequencies and
Hertz Omega and over 2 pi and that
becomes n over 2 L root G over and so
then the first natural frequency f1 is 1
over 2 L root of T over m now that let's
go back let's draw what's the mode shape
for the first mode well half a sine wave
vibrates like that it's full wavelength
I didn't leave myself quite enough room
that's half a wavelength right of a sine
wave so the full wavelength would be
like that this is of length L and so is
this piece over here so the lambda is 2
L for this particular problem how long
let's see how do I want to pose this
question
so how long does it take for a wave or a
disturbance to travel the length of the
this finite string
how long does it take you go down there
and back how would you calculate that
distance equals rate times time what's
the what's the distance 2l what's the
speed C so the length of time out to be
2 L over C right so the time required
and 2l divided by T over m that F 1 is T
over m divided by 2l mm-hmm
so the period so there is a direct
connection between propagation speed
frequencies wavelengths they're very
closely related so the natural frequency
of the first mode of this string that
frequency is exactly 1 over the length
of time it takes for a disturbance to
travel down and back
so with that a depth of understanding of
how the wave equation behaves you can
you can guess the behavior of lots of
other things that behave like that like
my rod here all I could do a little demo
with it in a second
so for example so this the longitudinal
vibration stress waves running up and
down this thing
obey the wave equation so if I take this
thing and drop it on the floor it'll
bounce off the floor how long does it
take to bounce off the floor so what do
you think actually what physics has to
have we know what's required to make
this thing bounce off the floor so let's
consider the floor infinitely rigid it
hits the floor it actually stays there
for some finite length of time and then
it leaves so physically when I was
holding up my string if I smack the end
what happened the pulse took off ran
down the end reflected came back and
that was one round-trip what he supposed
happens here I put a pulse into the end
is it a tension or compression the
strain that's felt compression so a
little compression pulse is put into the
end that compression pulse then trip it
when it first hits the compression and
the speed of propagation is finite so
that compression wave starts traveling
up here behind the compression wave this
rod has come to a stop in front of the
compression wave the rod doesn't know
what hit the ground yet it's still
moving down so the compression wave
travels up bring in it is decelerating
each little slice of mass as it passes
through it brings it to a stop and so
the compression read we eat reaches the
top end the cylinder has come to a stop
the end is free it can't take any strain
so an equal and opposite tension wave
has to start to make it this some of
them go to zero at the end the boundary
condition at the end is no strain so it
reflects is a tension wave now you have
a tension wave going down and what it
does is it accelerates every atom as it
goes by as it goes past it so everything
is stopped now now it starts down and
this Peete the part this thing starts
rebounding from
the top rebounds from the floor before
the bottom is top starts going up all of
it you can more and more goes up and one
hits the bottom the tension wave hits
the Florida it jumps off so how long
does it take all right
and what do you guess the natural
frequency of a free free rod is now it
has a funny mode shape the mode shape is
not half a sine wave like this the
distance is the displacement of the rod
it has free ends the ends are moving a
lot but I'll give you a clue I can hold
it in the center and not damp it what do
you think the mode shape looks like half
a wave like long ends are free cosine
maximum displacement goes to zero
maximum negative displacement so it's
half a wavelength long but it's a cosine
half a wavelength and the whole full
wave length is 2l all right so this has
mode shapes the mode shapes I've applied
different boundary conditions these are
free free boundary conditions the mode
shapes are cosine n PI x over L but they
have to obey a certain another law that
we know about conservation of momentum
if I because I've got gravity to deal
with I have to hang on to this thing but
I've picked a place to hang on to it the
youth you can hear it I am not affecting
the motion there's no motion or I'm
holding it so if I were out space I
could do this and just let it hang there
in space right and it would sit there
and ring what is happening to the center
of mass of this system as it vibrates
stationary so half of the mass of this
thing's got to be moving that way and
half of the mass has to be moving that
way so that the total senator mass does
well cosine mode shape positive here
negative they're perfectly symmetric
center-mass doesn't move so there's all
sorts of neat little problems that you
can solve too just by knowing the wave
equation and figuring out boundary
conditions okay
how you know how many of you stand in
the shower and home and sing and you
know and every now and then every now
and then you hit a note man you just
sound great right you know just all this
reverberation I don't even under the net
somebody said natural frequency of what
huh you've hit the net you've you hit
the natural frequency of the shower
stall itself you know if the shower
stall is a meter across pressure waves
and you plot pressure inside of the
shower the lowest mode if you're
plotting pressure well let's plot
actually molecular movement what's the
boundary condition at the wall the
molecules at the wall can't move right
zero so the molecular motion at
resonance in the shower stall the
molecules the pressure is making a move
back and forth looks like back to the
string again this is L the first natural
frequency of sound waves bouncing off
the walls in the stall is 1 over 2 L
root times C whatever C is and in C is
the speed of sound in air which is 340
meters per second so 340 meters per
second divided by 2l so if it's 1 meter
across here so it's 340 divided by 2 170
Hertz so that first note you can hit a 1
meter across shower style is about 170
Hertz pretty low okay but you could hit
second mode would be twice that and so
forth okay what about an organ pipe
this is an organ pipe wood it's got a
stopper to end let's do it without the
stopper that's an open organ pipe basic
wave equation how would you model its
boundary conditions so you can talk
about maybe particle molecular motion
just like this is now again it's just
sound waves so air particles and this is
now longitudinal things are moving
inside so what's the boundary condition
at this end free are fixed free and here
it's quite open so the boundary
condition down here is free so for the
molecular motion in the organ free free
organ pipe the you to get back to that
half a wavelength cosine thing and if
you want to plot pressure instead you
can write the wave equation in terms of
pressure pressure is its as pressure
relief here and pressure relief there so
in fact this if this is displacement of
the molecules pressure would plot like
that you'd have the pressure which felt
a pressure relief boundary condition but
again it's a half a wavelength long what
do you think first natural frequency of
this organ pipe is
whether people with a period would be 2
L oversee the frequency would be C over
200k
so the frequency for the organ pipe open
and f1 is C over 2l
now check your intuition I'm going to
close the end it's still an organ pipe
is a frequency gonna be higher or lower
take a vote how many think the frequency
is gonna go up raise your hands
commit all write down a lot of
uncertainty all right let's do the
experiment okay I find that actually
kind of counterintuitive until I learned
this I would have guessed the opposite
way what's going on with pressure in a
closed pipe well here at the orifice
where the sound is actually generated
it's the pressure we wanted to plot
pressure at the opening that's a
pressure relief place so it's 0 but at
the other end where the stopper is its
maximum how many wavelengths is that 1/4
and so in order the length of time it
takes for the thing to go through one
complete period is going to be for L
over C
half the frequency of the open pipe okay
so the way you could the wave equation
is really quite powerful governs lots of
things I want so I've got 10 15 minutes
left here I don't want you to go away
thinking that the whole world behaves
like the wave equation because there are
some important other physical systems
that we care about and the most I'm
going to show you just one and that's
the vibration of the beam
so here's cantilever beam whole table to
move it and that's you can see it up on
the screen ok so it's its first mode
vibration tip moves maximum kind of
looks like like a quarter wavelength
roughly is but not exactly so let's draw
a cantilever and you know most of you
have had to double a one so if you put a
load P out here bends goes through a
displacement Delta so you know that
Delta equals P L cubed over 3 e I all
right what's this eye area moment of
inertia right well you know you've been
doing dynamics all term we've talked
about mass moments ownership there's
also a area moments of inertia so this
is the area moment inertia of a cross
beam in this case our beam is a little
rectangular cross section and the
neutral axis is here a little variable Y
a displacement I is the integral of
y-squared da and da is just a little
slice of area here
da the integral of y-squared da is your
cross-sectional area moment of inertia
in the direction of bending okay it
health so that is I I happens you can
also write it as a Kappa squared a and
that's we had the grand into this and
dynamics we call the radius of gyration
you have the same thing in with area
moments of inertia the radius of
gyration this is gonna be really helpful
in a second so if you just solve the
force balance for a beam like I did for
the string take a little slice do force
balance for transverse motions I'm not
going to grind it out and and
temporarily neglect external forces and
damping I want to get to the natural
frequencies and mode shapes so the free
vibration no damping equation looks like
e I partial for W with respect to X to
the fourth plus Rho a partial squared W
with respect to t squared equals zero
and now this is density mass density and
the a this a is the area of the
cross-section
you know so it's just some BH right
would thickness times that width so Rho
times a is a mass per unit length and so
mass per unit length times DX would be
the little mass associated with the
element times the acceleration should be
the forces on the element so that's the
fourth order partial differential
equation that describes the vibration of
the beam and you have to where we saw
you have to apply the boundary
conditions and for the string it was
just a b1 cosine B to sign for the beam
that's b1 cosine plus b2 sine plus c2
Karsh plus d2 Cinch X and then you have
to apply for boundary conditions and
solve for you know b1 b2 and so forth
all four can all four of those I won't
do it but that's how you do it
separation and separation of variables
works again so we solve this apply the
boundary conditions apply the boundary
conditions what are the boundary
condition just so you understand what I
mean by the boundary conditions what are
they for a free free beam zero motion at
the wall no strain at the end no bending
moment the end no shear force at the
ends is no second derivative no third
derivative and at the wall there the
slope is zero the first derivative no
slope comes into the wall but doesn't
the slope is zero there so those are the
different kind of boundary is there
every different case you have a free
free beam have no bending at either end
and no strain at either end fixed fixed
beam no displacement zero slopes at both
ends and all different combinations and
every different combination gives you
different natural frequencies so you
apply the boundary conditions and for a
beam you find out that for all beams
Omega n can be written
some beta and a parameter squared I'll
call it times the square root of e I
over Rho a and this thing varies
according to the boundary conditions
okay now that's what you get shown in
every textbook in the world which it was
something but I have a very hard time
visualizing this you know you know
getting physical intuition by that but
so something you never see in a textbook
but I often do is let's replace I with
Kappa squared a and you get a square
root of e over Rho and the square root
of I over a but I as Kappa squared a the
A's cancel it's the square root of Kappa
cat square root of Kappa squared so this
and what's you know what e over Rho is
the over Rho square root of e over Rho
is the sound speed in a solid material
so the speed of that stress waves
traveling up and down this thing is the
square root of e over Rho for this is
aluminum and about it's about 4,000
meters a second so if you know just the
properties of the material you have that
and that says then the Omega in for
beams that some beta N squared a
parameter times Kappa CL and this thing
this is often written CL it's the
longitudinal Sound speed
this is Sound speed for waves traveling
through the medium so this tells you if
you make the beam twice as thick what do
you do to its natural frequencies
doubles instantly you know that so
bending properties depend a lot on the
radius of gyration
and I'll give you a few natural
frequencies for different boundary
conditions so you see what they behave
like
so the pin pin pin beam looks like that
so this is a you put a plank across the
stream you know rocks on both sides you
got a pin pin being basically it sit
there and rock so some length L has
properties e I so the natural frequency
is for a pin pin beam the beta ends are
just n PI over L and so your natural
frequencies Omega n looks like n PI over
L xx squared Kappa Co and for the
cantilever the cantilever the natural
frequencies look like Omega n PI squared
over 4 l squared is the beta N and I'll
write it this way again e I over Rho a
you can always go back and do that or
you can call it Kappa CL this is also
Kappa CL but then there isn't there are
some numbers you got to use here 1.19 4
squared that's the first mode second
mode 2.9 88 squared and then after that
5 squared 7 squared 9 squared so that's
the natural so this is the natural
frequency of a cantilever PI squared
over 4 l squared times one point one
nine four squared Kappa CL that's this
natural frequency
and a one final case because I can show
it to you the free free case so that's a
beam bending that vibrates like that and
I happen to know on a beam for the first
mode of a B this is first mode of a beam
where these nodes are where there's no
motion I should be able to hold it there
and not damp it and that turns out to be
at about the quarter points so whack it
like that and do it again alright so I
want you to hold it right there
nope can't hold it like that though it's
got to balance it because the Academy
right where the note is you can hear
that a little bit lower tone that's that
free free bending mode and it's just
sitting you can feel it vibrating a
little bit right but not much sure when
you're right in the right spot
you're right on the mode shape you know
I almost see it if you hit it hard
enough so that's the free free beam and
a free free beam has natural frequencies
Omega in again pi squared over 4 l
squared Kappa CL 3.01 1/2 squared 5
squared 7 squared 9 squared so as you go
up and in so that was the natural
frequencies of a free free beam oh one
last fact one last fact about beams so
let's say I have
this is now that's a steel beam under no
tension it can support its own weight
long tho so it can can a beam support
waves traveling down the beam transverse
waves traveling down the beam what I
think well if it can support this it can
probably support waves right so waves
will propagate in a beam even though
this is fourth order partial
differential equation but how fast do
they go that's the question
okay so this is a beam and I want to
know about waves traveling down it and
I'm not going to go through this would
take another hour so to show you where
this comes from but the here is my beam
here is a disturbance traveling along it
with some speed that I'm gonna call it I
gotta call it CT it's transverse wave
speed it's the speed you'd see a crest
of a wave moving at running down that
beam CT for a beam square root of Omega
Kappa CL and Cl again there's a square
root of e over Rho it's the speed of
sound in the material that property that
just turns up in here so what does this
tell you about the frequency dependence
of the speed there's a speed change with
frequency Omega Kappa CL
right it's proportional to frequency
high frequency waves go faster than low
frequency waves in a beam we I didn't
emphasize it when we were talking about
it but the wave equation what was C for
the string for the wave equation the
speed of sound the speed of wave
propagation was square root of T over m
was it frequency dependent always travel
at the same speed and so there's an
interesting
or consequence so for anything that
obeys the wave equation the speed of
propagation is a constant and
independent of frequency so I can make
any initial shape that I make in this
thing and let it go its initial
disturbance that little shape will stay
that shape and run up and down the thing
forever and that shape you can imagine a
little pluck like this to start with you
could imagine doing a making you know
doing a Fourier series to approximate
that it would be made up of a bunch of
different Fourier components right
and yet for something that Bay's the
wave equation that little pluck will
just stay the shape of the pluck and run
around forever but not so in a beam if
you did that in a beam if you come up
and put in impulse into a beam all that
energy would start out together but in
very brief time the high frequency
information would get out in front of
the low frequency information and if you
were way down this beam and somebody up
a mile away whacks one end and you're
down further along you'll say you'll see
high frequency waves pass you and then
lower frequency and finally a really
slow ones coming by the really long
waves so that's called dispersion so
beam waves are dispersive things that a
bay the wave equation are non dispersive
the energy all travels at the same speed
independent of frequency all right so
that's the that's it for the term I'll
see you guys on next Wednesday